whenever you see a nude scene in a movie
there's a good chance that nobody on set
ever really got naked often actors wear
flesh-colored underwear and for most
movies this is enough because intimate
scenes don't really factor into the plot
not true for the film adaptation of 50
Shades of Gray those scenes are the plot
which posed a unique problem for the
effects Department specifically because
it showed more skin than most other
films do a decision needed to be made
about whether or not Dakota Johnson's
character Anastasia Steele had a
personal grooming routine apparently she
didn't because a digital effects artist
had to go in during post-production and
use CGI to give Johnson
um one of these cinematographer Sheamus
McGarvey who would later refer to this
as one of the most surreal moments of
his entire career closely followed by
overseeing the hiring process of a
suitable butt double for Johnson